alors compte à rebours h - 10h pour le
réveillon les libations
bref la grande bouffe avec et c'est
moins drôle en perspective la gueule de
bois de demain n'est ce pas docteur
alors ces troubles s'est essentiellement
les maux de tête des vagues douleurs au
ventre
un état nauséeux et parfois des
vomissements et enfin une plus ou moins
grande fatigue
par des huîtres en vivra par des
poissons fumés divers et variés on
continuera par une volaille riesling et
on terminera par des fromages qui pour
accompagner de champagne nature voilà
c'est à vous de voir
oui à boire mariner avec une bonne bière
très bon truc de l'est c'est un
s'appelle reste au chaud c'est un verre
à peu près d'un demi la demie d'un
demi-litre enfin pendant trois ou quatre
et on le boit c'est un alcool blanc
alors c'est variable c'est la prune
séduit c'est ce qu'on veut finalement un
alcool blanc reste pochon normand seul
matin dans la botte de voir à ce cochon
franck aucun de ces trucs mais
l'efficacité démontrée et à mon avis ils
sont tous inutile en matière de
médicaments
il faut en prendre vraiment le moins
possible et se limiter par exemple
lorsque les maux de tête sont trop peu
inconfortable à des antalgiques tout à
fait mineurs de préférence d'ailleurs ne
contenant pas d'aspirine
rien de plus
vous n'y croyez pas regardez c'est trop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]